hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar enabling next-generation
targeted si RNA therapies with XP Chou
presented by dr. Ian Huggins
postdoctoral research fellow University
of California San Diego I'm Christie
jewel of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's presentation was previously
recorded I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send dr. Huggins will be answering
questions via the email address you
provided at the time of registration
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please use the
ask a question box and let us know you
are experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
click on that continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. Ian
Huggins dr. Huggins is a postdoctoral
researcher at University of California
San Diego where he builds advanced RNA
interference triggers for the treatment
of cancer and genetic disease he
specializes in the design cloning and
expression of engineered protein
targeting domains and utilizes multiple
by conjugation chemistries and
biochemical purification strategies to
produce high quality targeted protein
assay RNA triggers
your Huggins presentation will now begin
you
Wow I'm really honored to be here with
this group of people I'm excited to tell
you a little bit about what we've been
doing in Steve's lab to really push the
SI RNA therapy field forward
outside of some of the more conventional
tissue targets so my name is Ian Huggins
I'm a postdoc in Steve Dowdy's lab at UC
San Diego and I got started in this
field because I was I was interested in
genetic diseases that currently don't
have a treatment and in Steve's lab
we're trying to develop si RNA therapies
to treat these kinds of diseases so
those of you who aren't familiar with us
RNA I hope most of you are but just in
case you're not these are small
double-stranded RNAs that are able to
mediate silencing of virtually any gene
target in the human transcriptome there
are some great attributes that we think
make RNA an ideal drug people will say
drug the undruggable so you can actually
hit targets that aren't druggable by
conventional conventional small-molecule
means it's possible to target multiple
mRNAs and I think one of the most
interesting attributes of this kind of a
drug is that you can actually change the
sequence so there are some diseases that
will evade conventional therapies by by
a mutation right so cancer is a disease
that thrives on mutation influenza is a
disease that is known for mutation so si
RNA drugs in theory could evolve and
keep pace with those kinds of those
kinds of diseases there are some
drawbacks to this technology for one
thing for the last billion years our
cells have been evolving ways to keep
them out so SI rnas have 40 negatively
charged phosphate phosphate groups on
their backbones and that bounces them
right off the the cell membrane so
srna's are also rapidly degraded in the
serum and they are cleared by the
kidneys and they also trigger the innate
immune response in cells so there's like
all these negative drawbacks but one by
one in the dowdy lab we've developed
chemistry to address all of those things
and I can sum it up by saying we
developed by reversible neutral
phosphodiester backbone chemistry that
allows us to mask these molecules from
serum proteases allows them to bind to
serum albumin keep them from being
cleared and most importantly neutralize
some of those negative
charges so these molecules can be
delivered to to cells as long as they
have a targeting domain we and others
have successfully delivered these si
RNAs to to the liver by conjugation - at
risk I'll knock sugar moiety so the
liver is covered in these gal nak
receptors it's actually a silo
glycoprotein receptor and you can get
sapote and then sustained knockdown
after a single dose in mice and actually
the very first RNA interference drug was
approved last year and it targets a
liver enzyme for the treatment of a
hereditary amyloidosis so this is an
example of an SI RNA drug that's
treating a disease that nobody's been
able to hit with traditional therapies
so another drug that's in preclinical
trials rates in early clinical trials
right now is inclusive and it's actually
I think in phase 3 never mind but so
after a single dose of inkless around
patients were seeing nearly 80% knocked
down for up to six months of pcsk9 so
there's a lot of potential for these
drugs but so far people are really only
hitting the liver the liver is solved
Steve thought what if we could unlock
other tissues so we had this great idea
that we could leverage all the work
that's been done in Pharma developing
monoclonal antibodies for the antibody
drug conjugate field what if we just
took those antibodies off the shelf and
instead conjugated SI RNAs so you need
you need your molecules with a small
peptide linker with chemical conjugation
handles and if you could just conjugate
that to an antibody perhaps you could
get delivery to a wide variety of cell
types and get get the kind of knockdowns
that we're seeing in liver so when we
did a little back of the envelope
calculation we realized that to do like
a typical 10 mix per kick dose in an
animal we're gonna need about 0.25 mix
si RNA but because antibodies are much
bigger than si RNAs the math works out
to be about 1.3 milligrams of antibody
per Mouse per dose and we're a Bruin
academic lab you know we're kind of
little and when we buy antibodies from
companies we're used to buying them you
know like a hundred micrograms of
antibody for something like three
box so it became obvious really fast
that we weren't going to be able to do
this and we were gonna need to find some
way to do it in-house Steve came out of
his office we need to add a bodies and
and so then we had this impossible goal
that we had to meet so we did have an
established production system we were
using choake one adherent cells we do
transient transfection
and when we took our first generation
constructs and transfected them we did
get some antibody that we saw by western
blot so that wasn't enough it wasn't
going to work for us so so we needed to
have this stuff by the next month right
so we were trying to figure out well
what are our options obviously we could
try to make some stable clones but
that's going to take time and even then
we may not have high producers we've
thought about outsourcing production so
we actually got a quote for $3,000 for
five milligrams of antibody and a
timeframe of 12 weeks so that wasn't
going to cut it and you know one major
drawback of outsourcing your antibody
production is you give the production
company your sequence and then and then
they have it and you can't actually go
back and re-engineer it so a lab like
ours thrives with a rapid design build
test cycle so being able to have control
over the production and being able to
turn things around very quickly was key
for us so Arion a former a former
scientist in the lab was poking around
and he came across XP Cho and he was
looking at the product manual and the
brochures and he said oh there's no way
this looks way too good to be true but
it was the only option that fit in our
time frame so we got it up and running
in the lab it you know there's not
enough time here to show you all the
nitty gritty and the dirty pictures and
everything but it took a while to get
everything going and so we finally got
it all up we got our very first
transfection run and it was kind of
dirty there were a lot of hiccups in the
purification I don't know if any of you
have used XP Cho to make antibodies but
there's this dreaded yellow yellow gunk
and I can't tell you how many filters we
clogged with the yellow gunk but
needless to say we got about a milligram
of antibody out of a 30ml shaker flask
and so we were excited that was more an
antibody than we'd ever
out of any other system you know the
purity maybe left something to be
desired but we decided to push forward
and I wish I could tell you all the
things that we've done to make this
process better but but today with the
same antibody we're able to get huge
yields very clean there are a lot of
tricks I'm happy to talk to any of you
after if you're having trouble usually
we get about ten milligrams out of a 30
mil shaker flask for this particular
antibody it's really rock-solid and most
importantly we get very high pure
product that's easy to purify by
size-exclusion chromatography that's
gonna turn out to be important as I'll
show you in a couple of slides so I
compiled a record of the batch to batch
yields and you see like we started out
kind of low and we actually had some
some batches to where we got nothing and
maybe some of you have had problems like
that before and you'll find that once
you get this system up and running it
works really well but it tends to be a
little bit finicky so shake speed is
really important we have this shaker
where the band that actually drives the
shaking it stretched out and we didn't
notice until halfway through a
production run that it was shaking about
half speed and kind of like jerking
around and we didn't get any antibody
out we were having some problems with
transfection we were using these weird
tubes and when we switched tubes we
started to get antibody again basically
there are all kinds of things
temperature can go wrong and shaker
failed again so in order to make things
work we found that we needed to have the
shaker at about 140 rpm but you got to
be careful because when you turn your
shaker up it makes a little bit more
heat so there were all these little
tweaks that we had to that we had to do
but basically by the time we got
everything all figured out
we were getting solid yields including I
think one of these guys that tallest
peak is over one MIG her mill so that
was a 30 milligram antibody yield out of
130 ml flask so that was awesome so now
that we have these very nice pure
high-yield antibodies I can tell you
just a little bit about how we put them
together to build antibody
irony conjugates or arcs so you take an
antibody and enzymatically conjugate it
to a linker peptide that has chemistry
on the other end that facilitates
chemical conjugation to the si RNA so
we're just using quick chemistry to put
these si RNAs on the antibodies so the
first step was a little bit rough the
first time we did it so on the early
batches of kind of impure antibody we
got so here and you don't see my pointer
here in the left lane there's
unconjugated antibody you can see the
heavy chain and the light chain and then
there's some weird high molecular weight
contaminants we definitely see a shift
on the heavy chain when we conjugate the
linker peptide but then we also saw some
self conjugated antibody and it just
wasn't looking great but we stuck with
it we got some cleaner preps and we
optimized our conditions and now we
routinely produce let's see is it there
now we routinely produce super clean
single conjugate antibody kind of
antibody peptide conjugates so if you
replace that peptide with fluorescent
peptide you can see that these
antibodies specifically label C D 33
positive th P one cells but not C T 33
negative circuit cells so the antibody
that we're getting is all properly
folded it's not glycosylated in a weird
way that interferes with its binding it
basically does what it's supposed to do
so it's binding the cells it's I have
some other data it's being internalized
it's doing everything it's supposed to
so if you conjugate an infrared dye you
can actually see that this antibody
homes two tumors that we implanted
supplicated subcutaneously in mice and
that tumor signal persists for almost
about a week so we do get some liver
signal as well that's pretty well known
that antibody conjugates will tend to go
to the liver but we were still really
impressed that we could deliver these
straight to tumors so the next assembly
step is to take the antibody and click
on an SI RNA and this gel basically just
shows the shift on the heavy chain that
you get once you have a full sized SI
RNA and again we get such clean pure
antibodies that were able to produce
really clean pure conjugates so we have
a mantra in the lab that probably a lot
of you are familiar with
garbage in garbage out so we try really
hard to take good care and make sure
that we're very clean and produced good
molecules all along the way so then just
as a proof of concept we've taken this
anti CD 33 antibody and conjugated an SI
RNA that targets PL k1 which is a cell
cycle checkpoint regulator this
basically mediates g2 to g1 or G to 2m
progression so if we knock down peel k1
the cells will arrest in g2 and
eventually a fraction of them will die
so when I took this PL k1 arc and
treated th p1 cells I got an increased
knockdown or I should say decrease put
percentage of the cells in g1 both 2 and
4 days post treatment and it's just
quantified here it leaves a little bit
to be desired but the main point I'm
trying to make is that the XP chose are
not at fault here there are some other
things I need to work on so ongoing work
in the lab we actually have several
projects and many of them rely on
monoclonal antibodies so we've expressed
other antibodies as well so we have an
antibody that targets the ASG PR on
liver and we routinely get more than 10
milligrams of antibody from this in just
two weeks we were able to produce 100
milligrams of antibody which for a small
academic lab that's really that's really
amazing there's something that we
haven't been able to match with any
other production system we also have CD
71 antibody and transferrin receptor
that's another high producer between 6
to 8 milligrams of antibody per batch
took about two and a half weeks to get
to 100 milligrams finally you know there
are some tweaks that we've played with
to try and optimize yields probably the
easiest thing that you can do if you're
working with antibodies is to split your
heavy chain in your light chain onto
different constructs and then play with
the ratio so this particular antibody if
we decrease the heavy chain light chain
ratio to 0.5 we maximize the yield and
we still get a nice pure beautiful
single peak on chromatography so to
summarize the work that we're doing is
really made possible by the XP Cho
system it's been incredibly helpful for
us and we've had a lot of great print
active interaction with the people at
thermo they've been bending over
backwards to help us troubleshoot and to
help us really get this system up and
running and so just to summarize we've
been able to get a lot of antibody which
we need because we need more than one
milligram of of antibody per Mouse per
treatment this is really simple so even
a postdoc can do it it takes a little
bit of practice but but once you learn
the little the subtle I don't know the
personality of the XP Cho cells they
actually will perform really well for
you and you'll consistently get great
yields purity so what's really important
is that even though there does tend to
be some yellow crud in the in the crude
supernatant it's really easy to purify
very clean out of bodies out of this
system you don't get a lot of
contaminants that come along and finally
we're really happy with the versatility
of the system so we can put in all kinds
of different antibodies we've played
around with different liter peptides and
every time we throw something at this
system I'd say probably nine times out
of ten we get we get a really great
yield and we get a clean molecule that
does everything it's supposed to do so
to finish I just like to first
acknowledge my boss Steve dowdy that's a
picture of him surfing he's awesome I
love working for Steve he has a lot of
great ideas he's very supportive and
he's an eternal optimist these are
various members of the lab who've worked
on the si RNA project over the last few
years I'd like to point out are Ian van
der Bannon Berg who is now scientists at
thermo he did most of the expression
experiments in this talk that I showed
you today and he taught me what I know
about working with XP Cho and then these
two grad students Alex and Aaron did a
lot of the animal work and optimization
of the conjugation chemistry's so
finally I want to thank the guys at
thermo for working so closely with us
and for inviting me giving me a chance
to talk to you tonight
you
Thank You dr. Huggins for your
informative presentation now if you have
any
dr. Huggins please type them in the ask
question box and click send dr. Huggins
will be answering questions via the
email address you provided at the time
of registration we would like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
webcast can be viewed on-demand and
labret swill alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
you will now be redirected to the
registration page of our next webinar
expression purification and
characterization of difficult to express
membrane proteins in the XV 293 and
éxito expression systems a case study of
potassium chloride cotransporter KCC -
presented by dr. unasked Johari on
September 25th at 8:00 a.m. Pacific time
we hope to see you there
you